I think if I'm 40 and I don't have any  kids and I'm not married I would have a  baby artificially inseminated I would  feel like marry like Jesus is my baby I  always pee all over my Spanx it's a  disaster  they aren't crotchless enough I'll cry  at the end of the day not with fresh  makeup in recent years I'm like too cool  for duck face so that doesn't happen I  read that I was obsessed with killing  raccoons I had dinner with Obama once  and he just seemed very firm about the  change and that's like his motto well a  bear can juggle and stand on a ball and  he's talented but he's not famous you  know what I mean  I would like die to be in Twilight I  only just started wearing underwear a  month ago and I never wore underwear  until then  you